success isn't fun um it's hard effort
always goes end Noti get used to
it you're good you you never bother us
get it let us let us get it so there's
this myth that probably happens with
this influencer status of like we own
businesses and businesses grow in like
their last 3 months of Revenue have been
like yeah so if you look at this here so
what's been trending down as bookings so
we're having Jesus yeah tldr kind took
her eye off the B obviously was just
down 60% of what it was yep but the
thing about growth is that The Closer
you zoom into it the more Jagged it
looks and the more Jagged it feels you
can feel the knife's edge of the up and
the down and the up and the down every
single day in this Vlog you're going to
see me hop on a lot of calls and that's
because that's what a lot of running our
businesses is to Lea I nice to meet you
nice to meet you too I mean you just you
sprint from Air Conditioning to air
conditioning hey what what Happ just cor
roing it over here you know how it is
hello you have two doors in your room it
looks different it's clean now oh wow
what's up man how's it going good
congratulations on being you oh man
congrats on being you I don't know how
how a poor kid from Baltimore ends up in
Vegas all right guys I'm going to go
ahead and share my screen because of the
proliferation of social media
entrepreneurship appears to be the
things that look nice so it's the
private jets it's the cars it's the
watches it's the money but the thing is
is that all of those are outputs from
business that people use for personal
gain that then look attractive but the
actual doing this every day of
Entrepreneurship is predominantly
communication it's talking to other
leaders other employees teammates
vendors customers and when you look at
it on a real day-to-day of what that
looks like it's a lot of meetings it's a
lot of calls it's a lot of zooms and
those don't look good on Instagram CU
I've heard you talk about like paying
for you know like knowledge or their
expertise yeah at a certain point you
actually stop being able to pay for
expertise because when you start talking
to people who have a shitload of money
too like there's basically more valuable
things than money to trade like that's
where influence connections uh
introductions you know deals things like
that become a more valuable thing to
discuss there's free communities there's
paid communities there are benefits to
both you know paid communities sometimes
the the price tag is the gate to give
you some level of qualifier of you know
legitimacy like I mean even like you
join a golf club where it's $100,000 a
year to keep ling you're going to meet a
caliber of people that don't care about
spending $100,000 a year like it's a
very different type of person have you
just changed the five meals that you eat
cuz like everyone thinks that they give
up variety when they go on a diet
they're like I can't just stick to this
but people eat the same 5 to seven meals
yeah so I put 20 pounds back on and so
there's a key point there is I put it
back on it wasn't like the first time
I've been this way before
um after the book launch and that was
because actually going into the book
launch um it was the longest period I
think that I didn't work out I didn't
work out for like 6 weeks most people
eat the same five to seven meals and so
they think that like changing their diet
is going to have to be this massive
thing but you really just need to find
five to seven meals that you like
because you currently already like five
to seven meals and that's what you
already eat and so you have to swap
those for other stuff and if you just do
that you're 80 90% of the way they are
the older you get the fewer friends you
tend to have and that's not because
you're less social but it's because you
have standards even then man Even though
like my homiest of homies you can still
like you just slowly stretch out
communication then eventually
just it just Fizzles like it's hard you
have to maintain relationships so you
just don't put the effort in to maintain
it and then they usually just end like
if you're not in close proximity that's
the thing it's like most people's
friendships are out of convenience
they're not out of
design and so they're just friends with
people who were like lived across the
hall from them but what is the chance
that like the person lives across the
hall from you is actually going to be a
perfect fit for the type of person you
want to be with for a long time probably
not and
so I think people let friends happen by
accident rather than on purpose what
would you consider like a a unicorn of a
best friend like what traits would that
they truly root for you and they make
you better in multiple Arenas which is
basically like they are competent in
ways that you are not they have aligned
interest with you and ideally their
values align with yours that's a moment
it's just very hard to do all
three
cont people what's happening uh we were
going over a pricing issue for a
software about to roll out in one of our
larger portfolio companies and I think
the one of the emphasis they did made
the product not have a tenable pricing
structure so we were able to catch it
before they rolled it out which would
have literally cost millions of dollars
so we avoided that so great we got chops
chops always smells good though though
you notice that chops always yeah go for
it yeah I'm going to get I'm going a
little trim little chop I met Leila and
I had short hair and she said I think
you look good with long hair and I said
okay and then I didn't cut it and so
that was when my hair went from shorter
to longer and it's pretty much just
stayed there if you're an ugly guy you
might want to consider growing a beard
because it leaves half of your face to
imagination so I had this the when we
had gym launch uh this is right when we
transitioned we right started making
money and so remember we I had just been
like looking at bankruptcy lawyers like
a couple months earlier and so we have a
a meet up of 28 gym owners that come to
Alber cre New Mexico and I'm like super
nervous because I'm afraid that they're
just going to like think I suck or
whatever right so the night before you
know I was like trying to look nice and
so I had Scruff and so I for all the
guys who know this like you start
shaving down and just like getting
yourself in like different hair you're
like all right I'm going to do the
Wolverine and then I'm going to do
mutton chops like you work your way down
and so the last thing that I left was
this this big Gunslinger mustache so
like a big handlebar mustache and so I
like looked out of the bathroom at LEL I
was like hey um and she was like you
look ridiculous and so I looked back in
the mirror and I was like I think it's
perfect and so uh uh that actually makes
me sound cooler than I than I was what
really happened is I when I looked in
the mirror I was like well at least I
won't take myself too seriously and so I
figured that was that would like kind of
get because I was so nervous going into
it that I wanted to have some sort of
comic relief for myself as like a visual
reminder so I looked in the mirror I
think everybody's got fuel it's just
just not necessarily the one that is
sexy so a lot of the guys out there are
like find your passion find your purpose
but I think for most people their
purpose is like pay rent and not be
broke and so like if that's what you got
then that's what you use growth is
painful because you become aware of your
deficiencies reality shows you point
blank all of the areas you're weak in
and so when you've adjusted to something
you've kind of filled the gaps you
filled the holes between where you are
and what is required for that current
season but when you go into a new season
or you go to a new level and you battle
a new boss all of a sudden this guy has
a whole host of different skills that
you've never seen before and you just
get your ass beat over and over and over
again and those ass beatings hurt I mean
every everybody has lots of things they
hate like right now if I would ask you
what are 10 things that you hate about
your life it's probably you can come up
with them pretty fast but if I ask you
10 things you're grateful for it takes a
lot longer and so it's like rather than
trying and get people to be different
than who they are it's like find the 10
things you hate the most about your life
and use that the reason use those as the
reasons to to start working cuz I mean
like whatever you're going to do is
going to suck it's just whether it sucks
less than what your current existence is
and for me I had a lot of stuff that
sucked and so I just wanted to change
it's a nice backpack
bro where's device cing up on um so the
big thing that the internet doesn't
understand is that like Leila operates
acquisition. comom she's the operator
she does everything she's CEO she
actually is involved for the most part
in the day-to-day of the business um I
mean obviously I'll say hi to people you
know around the office and whatnot any
Shenanigans going on here no what was I
going to ask you oh I was going to let
you know um I brought the other half of
the chair in oh awesome yeah I brought
so it's right there where's
toes solo cross the
pond that is how we have found Lea and I
work best together is I work on like big
mey projects for extended periods of
time that are huge rocks that move
things forward and then Lea just like
basically through force of will just
keeps everyone on board everyone BL and
continues to hire and train and and
scale the business and that's what she's
exceptional at I mean that's why we're
able to build companies with such
Enterprise Value so quickly is that she
just understands building infrastructure
behind
things yeah I don't want to lose any
mask going down those stairs yeah my dad
told me he said he doesn't do cardio cuz
he wants to save his heartbeats I was
like check
out sounds legit he's a
doctor he's kidding he was joking that
was a joke hanging you um I'm going to
do this thumbnail and then I'll be Aude
where are we headed we're going to uh
ice coffee hour with graham Stefan and
Jack Selby we're going to talk about
iced coffee for
hours now I don't actually I don't know
what they want I don't know what they
want to talk about cuz I've been on a
couple times so I was like I hope I have
something new to say so we'll find out
cuz the thing is is that everyone is
waiting for this like one home run
that's going to like change everything
and that basically never happens because
it's all a game of incremental
Improvement it's about
small 1% improvements that add up over
time and while you're making the
improvements it never feels big it only
feels big in retrospect and it looks
like an overnight success from the
outside because whoever sees the
overnight success is never the person
who experienced the overnight success
because no one who actually is an
overnight success would describe it as
overnight because they always say you
guys don't see the 10 years that it took
me to get here I mean everyone wants
recurring Revenue but no one wants
recurring work and so it's this idea
that everyone wants to just like get get
get forever but no one wants to do do do
forever and one doesn't come without the
other and often times it's more like
recurring work with zero recurring
revenue for a very long period of time
before you get your first far less
amount of Revenue relative to the amount
of recurring work you do I mean think
about it until you win effort always
goes unnoticed get used to it with
whatever business you're getting into
the more difficult is to get into the
fewer entrance there will be so the less
competition you have to compete against
with the more barriers you have I'm
always amazed at the amount of people
who are like man this is hard and they
somehow say that like it's a bad thing
if it's hard good it means no one else
will do it more for you like the hard
the the level of difficulty that you
have to go through in order to get
whatever you want is literally the
barrier that everyone else has to go
through in order to achieve it too and
so the bigger the goal that you have the
bigger the obstacles that you have to
get over which is why so few people will
get it which is what makes it worthwhile
to be begin with if it were obviously
easy then everyone would do it and then
it wouldn't be a goal because everyone
would have it and right now it's not a
big goal for people to breathe because
everyone can breathe it's not a big goal
for you to put your shoes on in the
morning because everyone can do that and
so therefore it loses its value what
makes you exceptional is what you can do
that other people can't do which means
stomaching the harder thing is the thing
that makes you the
exception gr there we go what's up oh
that's the uh mailbox oh where's the
doorbell we're getting the doorbell move
next week you're good what's up man I'm
sweaty a little bit I'll give you one of
these how's it going man H yeah nice to
meet you pleasure pleasure you guys
would make an amazing podcast together I
have to say this would be a crazy
conversation oh sweet super cool yeah
but he's leaving right now for San
Francisco oh fun therapy okay cool and
they were out the mind that you thought
the therapy wasn't very effective I'm a
psychiatrist yeah yeah cool um and I was
explaining to them that if you believe
that therapy wasn't very effective you
may be surprised because I'm inclined to
agree okay well there you go then maybe
we agree yeah I thought there would be a
fun debate oh sure actually oh was four
was a gift from you no no from Eric what
is 1 hour of your time worth H I don't
know I probably wouldn't do anything for
less than 50 grand 50 Grand let's just
say for if someone wants your advice 50
Grand an hour this if this podcast is 2
hours long yeah whoever's watching this
is theoretically getting $100,000 of
value just by listening to this so I
just want to preface it by saying stick
around for the episode you're getting a
lot of value from this wow no that's
fantastic
no to the point that you might like why
not make 50 million um I think that I
want my brand to stand for something
more than that and so I made it the
mission to make real business education
accessible for everyone and that is what
I have been I have not wavered from that
since I started doing this and I have
two aspects to that one is like the
distribution of how do I get this to
everybody and how do I make it
accessible and that has multiple levels
to it which is one is like is it easy to
understand but also like is it fun and
entertaining and I'm getting better at
that I think I'm I'm better at the easy
to understand part I'm still working on
how do I make this more entertaining so
that like a stay-at-home mom will
actually click and maybe get interested
in something like this and maybe
recommend her son or her daughter to
like watch something like that I'm not
there yet like but that's like in order
for me to get that level of
accessibility like I need to get better
but on the flip side the context that
the content is consumed within is
basically my background so like at the
very beginning you're like hey just for
everybody who doesn't know here's this
guy right if I had said hey I make
$100,000 a year um listen to me I don't
I mean I think fewer people would listen
to me I mean maybe some would but like
far fewer would listen to me as a quote
Authority on on making money in general
you can't have both growth and comfort
one is the price of the other
and so like if you're really comfortable
it's probably an indication that you're
plateaued that you're in the same space
which then means that you have to
voluntarily go into pain in order to
come out the other side Better Stronger
Faster